la génération des boomers plus que toute
autre génération avant elle atteint le
décès des aînés pour hériter et latin
dégénèrent souvent en un spectacle
disgracieux c'est très intéressant que
c'est surtout très éloquent par rapport
aux rapports intergénérationnels pas
qu'on est professeur à la faculté des
sciences sociales de l'université
d'ottawa ça capte très bien les écarts
et les changements qui a eu depuis les
années 60 70
c'est de voir qu effectivement la
parentalité a changé d'une façon
dramatique pour le baby boomers la
notion du temps et plus pareil les gens
vivent dans le présent bien des baby
blues risquent d'être amèrement déçu les
sommes anticipées risque d'être
largement en deçà des espoirs et des
attentes
le problème en partie c'est que les
canadiens âgés de 65 ans et plus ne sont
tout simplement plus aussi riche qu'on
dise imagine les ja fr dt et beaucoup de
personnes ont contracté des dettes sur
la base d'une mensualité plutôt que
caracas internat au prix d'acquisition
de la gagne et gestionnaire de
portefeuille à gestion privée pic est
aussi auteur de deux livres sur la
planification de la retraite et de
l'investissement beaucoup de personnes
retraitées en commun fait un bond avant
leur grande maison qui était devenue
trop grande pour acheter un condo pour
acheter nos propriétés mais
contrairement à ce qu'on pensait et y
avait 25 ans au moment de la vente de
cette propriété le il dégageait pas le
capital qu'ils allaient venir compléter
des dépenses durant la retraite il
acheter une autre propriété à un prix
équivalent et le receveur et les
embarquer l'avant projet de rénovation
ou parfois ils achetaient une aux
propriétés qui coûtait plus cher
il augmente le fardeau de leur dette
plus rapidement que la moyenne des
autres canadiens
c'est ce que confirmait récemment une
étude publiée par l'entreprise de
vérification de crédit equifax en
général les retraités oui plamondon et
juristes et sociologues et porte parole
de l'association québécoise pour la
défense des droits des retraités
et là évidemment ce qu'il doit
9000 $ sur des cartes de crédit sur
lequel ils payent 9 au 24 et arriveront
jamais ça c'est une beau cadeau à
lafayette il nous on les encourage sa
faillite parce que y arriverons jamais
dont rémy d'arrêter de déclarer ça y est
et puis ils vont améliorer leur sens et
ont pu retracer paiement depuis sur dix
neuf mille dollars à steam vous voyez le
topo
depuis la dernière crise de 2008 vous
beaucoup de gens ont dû retourner
travailler parce qu'il avait perdu le
peu d'avoir qu'ils avaient dans certains
cas les fonds de pension sont un mise en
faillite donc perdre beaucoup de revenus
au niveau de temps on est à la retraite
denis prud'hommes et directeur général
du réseau de la fédération de l'âge d'or
du québec
donc oui plusieurs raisons font que
depuis je dirais 5,6 alors on revoit
sort en mars arrivée l'endettement chez
les plus âgés
on a de plus en plus de difficultés à
boucler les fins de mois
pour des choses essentielles l'on parle
pas de luxe je laisse les gens avec
avant pouvait se trouver retourner au
travail de façon temporaire pour se
payer un voyage dans le collège avait
pas de gros cons pension mais maintenant
fait même plus à maintenant les gens qui
ont travaillé pour boucler les fins de
mois avec la nourriture le logement
l'électricité est donc vraiment ce qui
est nécessaire les médicaments donc on
voit qu'un changement s'opère où
malheureusement les gens qui font pas
faire classe moyenne et est moins
s'appauvrissent continuellement la
réduction des montants d'héritage est
préoccupante non seulement pour les
boomers qui compte sur certain montant
pour houcine et leur propre retraite
mais il risque d'avoir des répercussions
maintenant en chaîne sur la génération
qui suit celles des boomers les moins de
40 ans devrait dans les faits ne pas
miser du tout sur l'héritage leur
provenant de la génération des boomers
il devrait apprendre à modifier
maintenant leur projet d' épargne et
leurs investissements en vue d'une
retraite qui répondraient financièrement
à leurs attentes les plus jeunes
al'avantage on le voit de lire quelque
chose donc on peut ajuster son niveau
dépend on peut ajuster sa stratégie
d'investissement de façon un combat et
puis bernard morency et conseiller
spécial à la caisse de dépôt et de
placement du québec
les baby boom 1 la majorité d'entre eux
son bien la totalité d'entre eux
christophe d'études qui dément que
rencontrent les seuls les plus
optimistes et déjà 75% des gens les plus
personnels
soixante pour cent des gens donc entre
60 et 75 des baby boomers sont assez
vite sa lfa l'air quand même 25 et 40
qu'ils sont costauds ils ont pas
beaucoup de choix lors ils sont le
premier choix c'est qu'ils réduisent
leurs attentes en termes de ce qu'ils
peuvent que se permettent un peu
deuxième c'est qu'il retarde un peu
alors votre attente qui met un petit peu
plus d'argent côté sa conduite 63 61 61
la troisième alternative pour russie de
faire une transition travaille
retraithon de travailler peut-être trois
jours semaine de façon à bonifier les
canadiens âgés moins fortunés qu'on les
imagine sont pourtant en meilleure
position que les personnes âgées dans le
reste du monde
l'organisation internationale du travail
est publié il ya quelques temps rapport
sur les conditions de retraite difficile
que vivent les personnes âgées un peu
partout dans le monde
un rapport qui a étudié la situation
dans 178 pays dans le canada bien sûr
près de la moitié des personnes âgées
dans le monde n'ont aucun revenu de
retraite
damana plusieurs pays en voie de
développement les jeunes au canada denis
latulippe est professeur titulaire à
l'université laval dans la ville de
québec il est aussi directeur de la
chaire d'actuariat de l'université laval
et il collabore également aux travaux de
cheikh sur les services financiers et
les changements démographiques au canada
tout le monde at war ii bat une fois
qu'elles auront atteint l'âge de 65 ans
à travers les fondations d'entreprise
c'est un défi parce que c'est pas tous
les travailleurs qui est passé avant lui
le reste on est en mesure de maintenir
leur du groupe fils dans un reportage de
radio canada international